- The real secret of everything
comes from this yellow pad.
(crowd oohing)
Hey, guys, welcome to
my night-time routine.
I'm gonna be sharing with you
everything that I do before I go to sleep,
as well as the scientific
reasoning for why I do it.
I'm trying to get the
best night sleep possible.
I wanna drive down my anxiety levels,
especially during the stressful time.
And finally three, I'm wanna get myself
ready to face tomorrow as
the best version of myself.
Before we get started,
let's give a huge shout out
to Sensodyne for sponsoring this video.
We're starting in the bedroom.
The bedroom, bedroom, bedroom, bedroom.
The reason why I'm starting here,
even though it's not bedtime just yet,
is because I wanna prep
my sleep environment
to be ready by the time I get to bed.
I really focus on three things here.
Temperature, humidity, and light levels.
These all need to be set ahead of time,
preferably two, three hours,
so by the time you get to bed
you're not rolling around
trying to fall asleep.
That's gonna peak your anxiety
and anxiety is the enemy of good sleep.
The first thing I do is
I set the temperature.
I ideally look for 65 degrees Fahrenheit.
The reason I do this is 'cause your body
naturally lowers its core
temperature while you sleep.
So if you can assist in the process
by lowering the environment temperature,
you're gonna be doing yourself a favor.
If you don't, and it's warm in your room,
your body's gonna try to
cool down by sweating.
And have you ever slept in sweaty sheets?
That's a bad night sleep.
Next, I flip on my humidifier.
The air can get quite dry in my apartment
because I am running the AC.
And dry air really irritates
the nasal passageways.
Leading to congestion,
scratchy throat, chapped lips.
It's really difficult to get
a good night sleep that way.
And I actually recommend a humidifier
to many of my patients in order to keep
their mucous membrane moist to potentially
decrease the likelihood
of them getting a virus.
The last piece of the puzzle
is to get rid of all
external sources of light,
and to make that happen I have
to close my blackout shades.
Scientific research has actually shown
that even small sources of light
can make it difficult for you
to fall asleep and to stay asleep.
I have made it complete
blackout situation in my room
and I really noticed the difference
over the last year or two.
We've wrapped up in the bedroom,
let's take it to bathroom.
First things first, getting
rid of the facial hair.
Now I used to shave before,
but then I realized it made me look
way too young to be a doctor.
I kept getting those
comments from my patients,
"You're Doogie Howser."
It was too much.
So now I use a beard trimmer
and really get that hair nice and short.
As well as using a shaver
in order to get rid
of scruff around my neck.
I think it still looks professional
but at the same time, it's
a pretty aesthetic look.
Next, I wanna give you a sneak
peek at my skin care routine.
Generally, I like to keep a pretty simple
with a Murad cleanser
followed by a moisturizer.
But on other days, I like
to get a little fancy
and I'm gonna show you that whole process
when I do a dedicated skin care video.
Keep a look out for that.
Last, but certainly not least,
is taking care of these pearly whites.
Look, your oral health
is intimately connected
to the health of the rest of your body.
We've actually seen
with scientific research
that those who have poor oral health
have poor cardiovascular outcomes as well.
You've gotta brush your
teeth at least twice a day.
Something you may not know about me
is that I have really sensitive teeth.
I've had braces twice in my life,
whitened my teeth probably once too much,
and because of that it's quite painful
to drink cold liquids like those
cookies and cream milkshakes.
Something I've been doing to combat it
is using Sensodyne
sensitivity and gum toothpaste
because it truly helps.
This is targeted for people
who have sensitive teeth of gum problems.
It's actually the number one
dentist recommended brand
for sensitive teeth,
definitely check it out.
Can't forget to feed the newf.
Now the newf's gotta poop.
Walking the newf during quarantine.
Sound might not be great.
This is actually my favorite part
of my night-time routine
because it really helps me wind down.
It's dark, it's quiet.
Nobody's out, it's a ghost
town except the newf!
The bear finally pooped.
Now it's time for me to go upstairs
and share with you a couple secrets
that I do to lower my anxiety before bed.
This is when my wind-down truly begins.
And I'm gonna take you
through the few steps
that I have laid out here
of things you need to do
in order to get into bed
and fall asleep really quickly.
First things first, I know the lights
in here aren't that dim
because I have the lights
I'm recording with,
but generally I only have that light
and that light on to keep it dim,
so that when I get to
bed, my melatonin levels
are at their highest point.
Melatonin is a sleepiness hormone
that gets released when it's dark.
It's part of your
natural circadian rhythm.
So the last thing you wanna do
is turn on all the lights
right before you go to sleep
and hurt that melatonin release.
You wanna keep that as high as possible.
Second, I have my sleepy time tea here.
(slurping)
I love green tea, but
green tea has caffeine.
You don't wanna consume
caffeine before bed.
Even if you're able to fall asleep,
it's not a good idea
'cause it'll interrupt
the stages of your sleep
and you're gonna wake up
feeling not refreshed.
So my sleepy time tea is chamomile,
no caffeine, it's an herbal tea.
There's something relaxing about it.
I love it, it's my go-to drink.
Next, the real secret of everything
comes from this yellow pad.
(crowd oohing)
It's nothing to do with this yellow pad.
It's just where I'm gonna write down
the next things I'm about to tell you.
First, create a to-do list
for the following day.
'Cause the last thing you wanna do
is get into bed and start thinking,
"Oh, I have to remember to
do this and this and this."
That's gonna keep you up.
Get it down on paper,
get it out of your mind.
Second, I'm gonna tell you
about the three good things.
The three good things is something
I wanted to tell you for the longest time.
I wanted to make a video dedicated to it
'cause I'm so excited about
the three good things.
It's actually a process
meant to decrease anxiety
and depressive symptoms
for up to six months.
And all it takes is every
night before you go to sleep,
to grab a yellow pad or a
non-yellow pad or your phone
and to write about three good things
that have happened to you that day
as well as a brief reason as to why.
For example, for me, number one,
I'll say Bear listened to me.
And the reason would be, lots of training.
It could be something as small as that.
It could be something as
big as your family member
had a graduation, you've met someone,
someone held the door for
you in the supermarket,
or you ate a yummy meal.
It doesn't matter as
long as it's positive.
The reason we're doing
this is we're retraining
our minds to let go of the anxiety
and think about the good things.
Our minds naturally have a
baseline level of anxiety.
That's how our ancestors survived.
But now it's much safer.
We're living in homes where
there are no natural predators.
So we need to think about
the positive things,
less so about the anxious things.
The patients that I've recommended this to
say it's a true game changer,
I stand behind it, they stand behind it,
and it's been researched in
psychiatric medical journals
saying that it truly does work.
Come on, bedtime.
It's bedtime for me,
but I'm gonna leave you
with three things that I recommend
you do not do before going to bed.
First thing, cell phone.
Get the cell phones away from you.
If you need to scan for urgent emails
from work or messages, that's fine.
But don't go on social media,
check out what your ex's doing,
get FOMO, that's gonna
peak your anxiety levels,
definitely don't do that.
Second, avoid heavy conversation.
You get into bed with your
partner and you're like,
"Why didn't you like what I was wearing?"
You're gonna be worn out.
You're gonna have a low will power.
You're not gonna give
the proper amount of time
to discuss the matter, so
save it for the next day.
And for number three, no news in bed.
There's so much anxiety
that's gonna be passed
on to you from there,
it's gonna make it
impossible to fall asleep,
save that for the morning
when you have your coffee,
your tea, you're ready
to go and face the day.
And I can go to the bed without saying
good night to the newf.
Good night, ol' puppy,
good night, good night,
good night, I love you, good night, yeah.
Leave your questions down below
and as always, stay happy
and healthy, and sleepy.
(hands clapping)
Thanks again to Sensodyne
for sponsoring this video.
(upbeat music)